[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat 90 minutes et deux grands thèmes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité et
voici le sommaire de ce 22 février
Emmanuel Macron a Rungis qui rend
hommage à la France qui travaille tôt un
taux de chômage au plus bas depuis 2008
des contrats d'apprentissage en nombre
record le gouvernement est-il en train
de réussir son Paris vers le plein
emploi ces chiffres sont-ils en trompe
l'oeil cette bonne tendance peut-elle
durer malgré la baisse de la croissance
on répond à toutes ces questions dans
une minute et puis comme chaque soir
cette semaine notre second débat est
consacré aux conséquences de la guerre
en Ukraine un an après l'invasion russe
ce soir on va analyser la stratégie de
défense européenne pour Joe Biden elle
passe d'abord par l'OTAN
nous devons avoir la sécurité en Europe
c'est aussi basique aussi simple aussi
important que ça l'OTAN est donc
l'alliance la plus importante je dirais
même peut-être l'alliance la plus
importante de pas seulement de
l'histoire moderne mais de l'histoire
tout court
à quel point l'Europe est-elle
dépendante de la puissance américaine
pour assurer sa sécurité commencer 12
mois de conflit on redéfini les à
hiérarchie des menaces l'armée et
l'industrie française sont-elles
adaptées à cette nouvelle donne
militaire ne ratez pas l'analyse de nos
experts dans 45 minutes mais d'abord
donc le plein emploi ce qui semblait
réservé à d'autres pays devient un
objectif bien français Hugo Lemonnier
c'est un chiffre historique le chômage
atteint les 7,2% au premier trimestre
2023 du jamais vu depuis la crise de
2008 nous avons désormais le chiffre du
chômage le plus bas en France depuis 15
ans je pense que nous devons poursuivre
la même direction avec l'objectif que
nous nous sommes fixés avec le président
de la République d'atteindre le plein
emploi en 2027 en France optimisme
affiché du gouvernement car malgré la
guerre en
la France continue de créer des emplois
avec des contrats de moins en moins
précaires la part des CDI a augmenté et
quand on regarde dans les nouveaux
contrats signés alors qu'on était sur
une tendance ou on avait de plus en plus
de contrats courts et même des contrats
très courts des contrats de moins d'un
mois même des contrats d'une semaine
c'était ce type de contrat qui est
stimulé avant la crise covid aujourd'hui
on se rend compte que c'est de plus en
plus du CDI et cette tendance soulève
une question de fond comment l'économie
française arrive-t-elle à créer autant
d'emplois avec aussi peu de croissance
la cause serait à chercher du côté de la
baisse de la productivité il faut
aujourd'hui plus de travailleurs pour
produire une même quantité de croissance
qu'auparavant dans le premier cas de
figure si les gains de productivité
venaient à augmenter dans l'avenir et
ben à la baisse du chômage on a sans
doute mangé notre pain blanc et donc
malheureusement il y aura moins de
création d'emplois et le chômage devrait
même repartir à la hausse c'est le
scénario de l'omce pour 2023 le célèbre
du gouvernement si on reste avec ses
gains de productivité faible et donc du
coup même avec très peu de croissance on
va continuer à créer des emplois et le
chômage va continuer de baisser le
gouvernement table sur 1% de croissance
pour 2023
bientôt le plein emploi c'est notre
question fil rouge avec Stéphanie
Villers bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
conseiller économique à PwC France
Clément Carbonnier bonsoir bienvenue
professeur d'économie à l'Université
Paris 8 codirecteur de l'axe politique
socio fiscal du laboratoire
interdisciplinaire d'évaluation des
politiques publiques de Sciences Po
c'est long mais je l'ai dit et vous
publiez ce livre les femmes les jeunes
et les enfants d'abord investissement
social et économie de la qualité aux
presse universitaires de France Richard
Berly bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
correspondant France Europe pour le
média Suisse Blic et j'accue également
Mathilde Sirault bonsoir Mathilde vous
retrouver jean-y poétique éditorialiste
pour sens public je redonne des chiffres
pour pour démarrer
les chiffres de du 4e trimestre 2022
avec cette baisse de 3,6% pour les
chômeurs catégories A ça représente
moins 114000 demandeurs d'emploi sur ce
dernier trimestre de l'année 2022 et ça
met le taux de chômage à 7,2% du jamais
vu depuis
15 ans on va évidemment analyser ce
qu'il y a derrière ces chiffres parce
que ça c'est brut quelle qualité pour
ses emplois et puis quelle perspective
on peut on peut donner à l'économie
française Stéphanie Miller l'objectif du
plein emploi on peut rappeler c'est quoi
taux de chômage autour de 5 %, c'est ça
ce que nous dit l'organisme
international du travail il le situe à
peu près autour de 5%, est-ce que c'est
réaliste d'ici la fin du quinquennat
puisque c'est l'objectif affiché du
gouvernement déjà c'est très compliqué
à savoir parce que 2027 c'est quand même
dans quatre ans et d'ici là il peut se
passer pas mal de choses et je rappelle
quand même que l'essentiel pour faire
baisser le chômage c'est la croissance
or on sait ce qu'on sait c'est que 2023
va être moins bon a priori que que
2000-2022 les prévisions de croissance
sont plutôt autour de 0,5% le le
ministère de des finances croit un taux
de croissance autour de 1% mais c'est
assez audacieux donc dans un contexte
avec une des perspectives de croissance
un peu plus faible il est compliqué
d'imaginer que le taux de chômage
continue de reculer déjà se stabiliser
autour de 7%, c'est ce qu'il est en
train de faire d'ailleurs depuis depuis
quelques mois c'est déjà une ambition
pour 2023
Clément carbonier est-ce qu'ils sont en
trompe l'oeil ces chiffres du chômage je
l'ai donné que la catégorie A on sait
que dans les autres catégories la
situation est un peu plus complexe alors
il y a comme ça a été dit dans
l'introduction il y a des des vrais
créations d'emplois y compris des
créations en CDI mais ça c'est
effectivement le point qu'il faut voir
c'est à dire que le la question du plein
emploi à mon avis n'est pas à regarder
du côté du taux de chômage mais beaucoup
plus du côté du taux d'emploi ça peut
paraître
enfin ça peut paraître obscur de le dire
comme ça mais en fait il est très
important de faire la différence entre
les deux la différence la grande
différence entre les deux c'est les
inactifs c'est à dire que le taux de
chômage c'est le nombre de chômeurs
rapportés au nombre de personnes en
emploi
considéré comme en recherche d'emploi et
évidemment ça ça ne prend pas en compte
les gens qui ne sont pas considérés
comme en recherche d'emploi alors que le
taux d'emploi c'est le nombre de
personnes en emploi rapporté à tous les
gens qui sont en âge d'être en emploi et
donc là il y a une grande différence la
grande différence juste pour donner une
idée de cette à quel point ça peut
changer fondamentalement les choses si
vous prenez les États-Unis sur la
tranche par exemple ce qu'il y a des
questions particulières je pense qu'on
les abordera des jeunes et des personnes
âgées de fin de carrière si vous prenez
la tranche médiane des âges des milieux
de carrière les États-Unis ont beaucoup
moins de de chômage que par exemple en
Europe mais ils ont beaucoup moins
d'emplois aussi en fait c'est d'ailleurs
que derrière il y a une labellisation
des gens qui certes ils ont moins de
chômeurs mais ça veut pas dire qu'ils
ont plus de gens en emploi c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont plus de gens qui ne sont pas
considérés comme en recherche d'emploi
qui sont considérés comme une j'entends
cette argument mais le
les chiffres qui nous permettent de
d'évaluer finalement une politique
gouvernementale depuis des années voire
des décennies ce sont quand même ces
chiffres
[Musique]
quand je vois par rapport aux entretiens
que je fais ou rencontres que je fais
qu'il y a un facteur confiant qui est
revenu confiance dans le système c'est
peut-être là où quand même les réformes
Macron ont marché sur le thème de la
flexibilité du travail sur le thème des
licenciements plus facile selon les
critères français circule il est il est
peut-être moins angoissant aujourd'hui
pour un entrepreneur d'embaucher
quelqu'un y compris de l'embaucher et de
manière indéterminée que ce n'était le
cas auparavant si c'est vrai c'est mon
sentiment par rapport à mes j'irai à mes
rencontres c'est quand même une victoire
parce qu'un des problèmes en France on
le sait c'était la paralysie du marché
du travail ou beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
finalement réfugier leurs employés dans
la précarité parce qu'ils avaient peur
d'assumer la conséquence d'un contrat à
durée indéterminé alors justement est-ce
qu'on peut donner crédit finalement au
gouvernement de de ces chiffres bah
évidemment quand on entend le
porte-parole Olivier Véran la réponse
est oui on l'écoute
il semble loin le temps du pessimisme en
2017 nous étions élus pour lutter contre
le chômage de masse désormais nous
tutoyons le plein emploi malgré la crise
de l'inflation malgré la pandémie malgré
la guerre aux portes de l'Europe je
voudrais vous dire que cela ne doit rien
au hasard et tout tient à la politique
conduite depuis plus de 5 ans dans notre
pays bon on n'attend pas autre chose
importante par le gouvernement c'est
fait vivir est-ce que vous vous créitez
le
l'exécutif on peut intégrer Emmanuel
Macron dans le bilan des des six
dernières années ce qu'on peut voir dans
les chiffres c'est qu'il y a
véritablement eu des créations d'emplois
et une baisse du taux de chômage chez
les jeunes c'est à dire chez les moins
de 25 ans mais ça c'est pas fait tout
seul c'est fait grâce au contrat
d'apprentissage avec des soutien qui ont
été mis en place par l'État avec une
prise en charge entre 5000 et 8000 euros
par jeune pour l'entreprise donc c'était
effectivement ça a été un effet
d'aubaine et ça a incité les entreprises
à la sortie de cette période pandémique
de d'aller
recruter plus de jeunes et véritable
puisqu'en 2021 il y a eu quand même 700
000 créations de contrats
d'apprentissage et en 2022 il y en a eu
800 donc et cette année a priori on peut
rester sur une belle tendance parce que
les mesures ont été un peu prolongées il
y a des aides jusqu'à 6000 euros par
jeune c'est un peu moins que la des
précédentes mais ça reste quand même
stimulant c'est important mais à quel
prix la Cour des comptes faisait ce
bilan pour l'année 2021 on n'a pas les
chiffres de 2022 encore c'est trop tôt
ça a coûté plus de 11 milliards 11,3
milliards d'euros alors c'est une vraie
question est-ce que c'est de l'argent
public bien placé je vous la pose et
puis ensuite vous aurez votre alors là
pour le coup oui parce que c'est on voit
bien que ces contrats d'apprentissage se
transforment très rapidement et le plus
souvent majoritairement en emploi donc
ça c'est une bonne chose on savait que
toute la difficulté du marché de
l'emploi en France c'était ces jeunes
qui n'arrivaient pas à intégrer à
rentrer sur le marché du travail après
sur la productivité il faut voir il faut
accepter qu'on ait une productivité plus
pourquoi parce que quand ces jeunes
arrivent sur le marché de l'emploi ils
sont considérés comme être actif pour
autant on peut pas leur demander d'être
productif comme quelqu'un qui qui est
déjà qui a fini ses études donc en fait
moi je suis pas inquiète on me dit en
voyant qu'une la productivité en France
est en train de baisser il faut juste en
fait accompagner ces jeunes pour qu'ils
acquiert une productivité comme un actif
qui est à temps plein au travail c'est
intéressant Clément Carbonnier de cette
question de l'apprentissage parce que on
est aussi au cœur de du débat sur la
qualité des emplois dont on parle
c'est-à-dire que certains disent il y a
un effet domaine pour les entreprises et
puis attention à des des des salariés un
peu un peu j'allais dire sous-traiter
non mais vous voyez de de faux salariés
quoi pour pour les apprentis est-ce que
est-ce que vous faites ce constat ou pas
ça peut alors il y a la question des
conditions de travail il faudrait y
revenir peut-être c'est y compris
l'apprentissage c'est quelque chose de
très important et très positif
maintenant c'est quelque chose qui est
positif dans le cadre de la formation et
et derrière il y a aussi des vases
communicantes en fait il y a des moyens
qui ont été mis très forts sur une
partie de la formation des jeunes qui
est l'apprentissage et il y a toute une
autre partie qui est qui est en gros
manque de moyens donc il y a des effets
à court terme assez rapide parce que on
avait du manque d'apprentissage
effectivement maintenant si on fait
cette apprentissage mais ces moyens dans
l'apprentissage en continuant à ne
mettre aussi peu voir à enlever à à
l'éducation pour le au sens général y
compris l'éducation supérieure qui va en
parallèle c'est à dire que cet
apprentissage effectivement il y a le
côté de que les gens doivent avoir les
les jeunes doivent avoir cette place
dans l'entreprise est-ce que ça doit
être encadrer
parce qu'il est pas plus efficace là en
apprentissage dans une entreprise que
dans une filière de l'enseignement
supérieur sans déboucher parce que
c'était aussi ça l'une des questions
sans déboucher il y a une grosse il y a
un gros points
plutôt mettre cet argent
je dis pas que c'est à la plage je dis
juste que ça suffit pas c'est-à-dire que
l'apprentissage le principe de
l'apprentissage c'est que c'est dans un
cadre de formation c'est l'apprentissage
c'est pas on on met un jeune à
l'apprentissage et puis c'est
l'entreprise qui va le former c'est pas
comme ça c'est c'est justement dans le
cadre d'une formation d'accord d'une
formation on a une partie de
d'enseignement théorique d'enseignement
de compétences et on a une partie de
mise en pratique et effectivement mettre
ces deux choses ensemble c'est très
important pour la formation pour avoir
des gens plus productifs en tout cas à
moyen terme tout ça c'est important mais
si derrière on met d'un côté c'est à
dire le lien entre les compétences et
leur mise en pratique dans l'entreprise
mais qu'on ne met pas sur la création
des compétences théoriques elles-mêmes
bah il y a un moment où ce cette
ressource là de l'apprentissage elle va
se tarir parce que cet apprentissage il
se construit sur sur la constitution de
compétences théoriques et peut-être une
comparaison européenne puisqu'il se
trouve que la Suisse comme l'Allemagne
sont des pays vous le savez ou
l'apprentissage est très développé
première remarque l'apprentissage est
quand même et ça on le trouve dans ces
deux pays la condition du maintien ou du
retour de filière industrielle or c'est
ce qu'on veut faire en France
c'est-à-dire ramener les filières
industrielles l'apprentissage joue un
rôle notamment dans le maintien de
nombreuses PME et on sait que les PME
allemandes sont souvent cités en exemple
deuxième élément ce qui est au fond en
train de faire Emmanuel Macron sans le
dire c'est de ramener la formation aux
besoins du marché du travail de
rapprocher le système des besoins des
entreprises et que sa stralgie que ça se
traduise pardon par des embauches bah ça
prouve que ça marche sauf que en France
il y a quand même là une différence
d'appréciation par rapport à un pays
comme l'Allemagne ou la Suisse dire
qu'on doit former les gens pour les
besoins des entreprises ça c'était quand
même assez tabou et ce tabou et
peut-être en train de bouger de basculer
notamment parce que une des réformes au
programme c'est celle du lycée
professionnel et le gouvernement veut
aussi s'engager sur la
revalorisation des filières courtes et
qui soit vraiment ciblés vers un métier
en particulier qui va de pair avec ce
que vous disiez cet objectif de
réindustrialisation
cette question là est justement on
revient sur un effet à court terme ou à
long terme c'est à dire que s'adapter à
dire en fait les formations maintenant
vont s'adapter aux besoins des
entreprises aujourd'hui à va avoir un
effet à court terme maintenant si on
veut une économie dynamique est-ce que
c'est forcément le marché et les
entreprises sur ce marché qui sont les
meilleurs pour prévoir quels seront les
besoins de demain on a eu quand même des
exemples sur les derniers moments où en
fait ce fonctionnement là il est pas
forcément efficace pour savoir de quelle
compétences on aura besoin demain et
donc derrière le fait de passer c'est
pas juste question de d'idéologie est-ce
que c'est les entreprises solides c'est
aussi une question est-ce que les
entreprises par rapport à leur
contrainte qui sont des contraintes
notamment alors évidemment elles
essayent de penser à court terme à long
terme mais c'est aussi beaucoup des
contraintes de court terme qui sont
aptes et si on leur donne tout le
pouvoir de décider quels sont quels sont
les compétences qu'on doit développer
pour demain c'est un problème et donc je
pense que derrière c'est aussi par
rapport à ça ou c'est très important
d'avoir de l'apprentissage pour avoir de
la main d'oeuvre d'une certaine manière
efficace tout de suite pour les
entreprises mais de le mêler à de la
formation théorique et généraliste parce
que c'est par la formation généraliste
qu'on a l'adaptation de la main d'oeuvre
et quand on arrive dans une dans une
crise il faut que cette main d'oeuvre
s'adapte et elle est adaptable si elle a
eu une formation généraliste et c'est ça
c'est pas l'apprentissage qui lui donne
et c'est vrai qu'il faut notamment avec
des métiers qui seraient inventent en
permanence on est dans cette situation
là aujourd'hui moi je veux bien y croire
cela dit jusqu'à présent la formation
universitaire était assez critiquée
parce que les entreprises disaient bah
justement c'est tellement déconnecté de
notre réalité et ça crée une situation
de de chômage chez ces jeunes là donc là
c'est l'apprentissage pour moi c'est
quand même une réponse pour essayer de
concilier à la fois la formation
théorique qui est importante et puis la
formation de théorique peut-être qu'elle
crée plus de créativité et plus
d'adapter pour le monde de demain il
n'empêche que les moyens donnés aux
universités françaises sont certainement
pas assez suffisantes et on le sait pour
créer les les fonctions de demain il y a
quand même ce problème là c'est à dire
qu'on peut pas uniquement dire qu'il
faut conserver un enseignement théorique
il faut que l'enseignement théorique
aille vers plus de recherches donc plus
de moyens pour réellement adresser un
vrai message sur le long terme
on a vu des entreprises ou des secteurs
d'activité créé leur propre écoles d'une
certaine façon parce que parce que le
système
scolaire universitaire finalement était
en décalage quoi
du mal en tout cas je parle jusqu'à bac
+ 5 à se mettre à la page en ordre de
marche et à absorber en fait les
nouvelles technologies on est je alors
que les pôles de recherche sont quand
même plus innovants il manque quand même
c'est cette confronte confrontation dans
le système universitaire alors je suis
pas du tout d'accord il y a il y a chez
les jeunes effectivement souvent des
temps avant de trouver un premier emploi
mais enfin chez les diplômés de de
l'université c'est pas là qu'il y avait
le problème du chômage donc c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai que l'université
était totalement décalage que ces
gens-là ne trouvaient pas d'emploi sur
l'innovation et d'ailleurs quand on
regarde les différentes manières de voir
parce qu'effectivement ça fait partie de
cette chose-là quand on voit les
différentes manières de de créer de
l'innovation y compris de l'innovation
applicable pour les entreprises quelles
sont les manières qu'on marchait est-ce
que c'est le crédit d'impôt recherche où
on donne directement aux entreprises etc
ou est-ce que c'est ce qui a mieux
marché conséquent justement ont donné de
l'argent aux universités et là je suis
totalement avec d'accord avec vous il y
a une question de moyens mais ce moyen
est d'ailleurs quand on donnait de
l'argent non pas aux entreprises mais
aux universités les entreprises qui
étaient dans le dans le rayon de contact
d'une certaine manière et d'interaction
avec cette université ces entreprises se
trouvaient à être plus innovantes etc
donc ce qui ce qui marche c'est pas
forcément de toujours dire c'est il va
falloir aider les entreprises
directement on les aide aussi on les
aide en investissant dans les
universités on les on les aide en
investissant dans le savoir je ferme ce
premier chapitre consacré à
l'apprentissage on va parler maintenant
de l'assurance chômage puisque pour
atteindre ce plein emploi le
gouvernement mise aussi sur cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage quand un
Calmet vous êtes là les règles bonsoir
Quentin en matière de d'indemnisation
ont changé depuis le premier février
exactement l'indeviliation chômage varie
désormais en fonction de l'état du
marché du travail c'est une idée qui
avait proposé Emmanuel Macron pendant la
campagne présidentielle et c'est ce ce
qu'on appelle la contracyclicité l'idée
et qui a été mis en place avec cette
réforme c'est de durcir les règles
d'indemnisation en l'occurrence la durée
quand la situation du marché du travail
est bonne et quand des emplois sont à
pourvoir à l'inverse les règles
protègent davantage les demandeurs
d'emploi quand le taux de chômage repart
à la hausse il est donc d'inciter les
chômeurs à occuper les postes non pourvu
avec cette réforme Thomas le
gouvernement a même tablé sur 100 à 150
000 retours à l'emploi mais le
gouvernement tergiverser on va dire sur
cette réforme une sorte de volte-face
oui on peut même dire à quoi je crois la
réforme a bien été adoptée par le
Parlement c'était à l'automne dernier
avec des critères exacts qui devaient
être fixés ensuite par décret à ce
moment-là le gouvernement consulte les
partenaires sociaux puis publie à la
veille de Noël des critères bien plus
stricts que ceux qui avaient été prévus
discuter depuis le début avec les
partenaires sociaux regardez la
réduction des droits est alors de 40% de
la durée d'indemnisation
le taux de chômage venait à tomber sous
les 6%. le V de boucliers des syndicats
le gouvernement rétropédal après les
vacances écoutez ils avaient band sur
France Info on prévoit de passer une
indemnisation de 24 mois à 18 mois en
effet l'hypothèse on a voulu être
transparent en affichant toutes les
toutes les situations et les règles qui
s'appliqueraient y compris si le taux de
chômage ce qu'on souhaite évidemment
passe en dessous de 6% moi j'entends que
ce point n'a peut-être pas suffisamment
fait l'objet de discussions donc nous
allons le retirer à cette troisième ce
troisième niveau du décret qui entrera
en vigueur au premier février et nous
remettrons ce sujet dans la concertation
sur les futurs règles de l'assurance
chômas donc finalement le critère qui
s'applique bien c'est un recul de 25% de
la durée d'indemnisation pour un taux de
chômage sous les 9%, le décret est
effectivement entré en vigueur le
premier février de leur côté l'ensemble
des syndicats c'est opposé à cette
réforme peu importe d'ailleurs les
critères qui avaient été retenus et
avant même que le décret ne soit publié
regardez ce tweet qui date de novembre
de Laurent Berger à la CFDT qui a ainsi
évoqué à des règles
inefficaces et injustes attaquons-nous
au vrai problème attractivité des
métiers freins à l'emploi formation
arrêtons de stigmatiser les demandeurs
d'emploi comme le fait le gouvernement
avait écrit avait-il écrit en novembre
dernier merci Quentin pour toutes ces
explications Richard Verly cette réforme
de l'assurance chômage c'est c'est quoi
c'est du bon sens de la souplesse ou
alors de la stigmatisation des chômeurs
pour reprendre les les termes de Laurent
Berger c'est quand même encore une fois
pour prendre un peu de recul un
alignement de la France sur ses voisins
et sur les pays européens la France
avait et a toujours je crois d'assez
loin le système social le plus
protecteur pour les demandeurs d'emploi
donc la protection diminue effectivement
avec ce système variable ça la rapproche
de ses concurrents européens pourquoi je
dis concurrent parce que les voisins
deux facto sont aussi des conc quand on
sait que les entreprises ont souvent des
usines ou des centres de maintenance
dans les différents pays c'était
sûrement indispensable parce qu'il faut
un moment donné s'aligner la deuxième
chose est-ce que c'est comme le dit
Laurent Berger impitoyable pour les
chômeurs est-ce que ça revient à
culpabiliser les chômeurs d'une certaine
manière oui je crois que c'est difficile
mais encore une fois on a l'âge je
dirais le programme d'Emmanuel Macron
qui se déroule qui se déroule d'une
manière pas toujours dite pas toujours
comme ça assumer mais qui consiste au
fond à avoir un marché du travail
beaucoup plus flexible beaucoup plus
favorable aux entreprises peut-être
qu'il ne l'est au travailleur Clément
Carbonnier il y a une double critique
dans les propos de du secrétaire général
de la de la CFDT c'est effectivement il
y a la justice et puis lui il dit
inefficace qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
le problème c'est quel est l'objectif et
le plein emploi c'est l'angle du débat
quel est l'objectif du plein d'emploi
c'est une vraie question et donc vous
avez commencé votre émission en parlant
de l'intervention à Rungis il faut
travailler il faut travailler en plus
pour crier plus de richesses mais on
travaille plus dans quelles conditions
et quel type de richesse on produit un
autre point qui était intéressant alors
voit bien tu chaque fois qu'on fait
appel au bon sens c'est toujours un peu
suspect et donc là en l'occurrence le le
bon sens serait forcément le bon sens ce
n'est pas suspect quand on fait appel au
bon sens plutôt de développer l'argument
quand les politiques disent ça d'accord
je comprends ce que vous voulez dire la
question est celle-là et de la même
manière le fait de présenter la gestion
d'une société ou d'un État comme la
gestion d'un ménage ce n'est pas la même
chose et notamment il dit on va non
parce que sur le point de la richesse
c'est important ce qui est important
mais je voudrais vous entendre sur le
dispositif en question justement c'est
parce que c'est ça le point
le ménage l'exemple du ménage c'est de
dire bah si on a plus de richesse on est
les richesses en fait elle est monétaire
elle est totalement transformable en
n'importe quoi et donc on peut avoir ce
dont on a besoin c'est pas le cas au
niveau d'une société c'est-à-dire que au
niveau d'une société si on produit plus
de services de soins on a plus de
services de soins si on produit autre
chose on a plus d'autres choses alors on
peut essayer de compenser sur les
marchés internationaux mais pas
totalement et donc derrière il y a ce
qu'on produit comment on le produit et
pour qui on le produit c'est à dire le
partage et donc là à qui ça profite et
et donc là on voit bien la question le
plein emploi qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand on fait pourquoi on a ce système
là ce système de l'assurance chômage
l'assurance c'est une assurance donc
normalement c'est le risque c'est si
vous tombez quand on a une assurance
santé l'assurance pour c'est si vous
avez une pneumonie on vous soigne contre
votre pneumonie il y a plus de pneumonie
l'hiver que l'été pour autant on va pas
moins vous soigner si vous avez une
pneumonie VT parce que certes il y a
moins de pneumonie l'été mais les gens
qui ont la pneumonie ont autant besoin
d'être soignés est-ce que vous pensez
que ça va marcher c'est ça ma question
c'est la même chose c'est-à-dire que
certes quand ça va mieux quand il y a
plus de croissance il y a moins de
chômage mais les chômeurs ont autant
besoin d'être protégé l'idée c'est
effectivement de leur dire ben vous
allez aller dans des endroits où vous
êtes pas compétent pour dans des
mauvaises conditions parce que le plein
emploi si c'est vraiment le plein
d'emploi pour la société quand on a le
plein emploi et on peut améliorer les
conditions et on revient donc à la
qualité de l'emploi on y revient je vous
en fait ça alors pas augmenter les
salaires pour efficace ou face les
familles pardon nous interrompre mais
c'était un peu long et Stéphanie viler
efficace ou pas en fait c'est c'est
effectivement tout dépend de la qualité
c'est vrai de l'emploi parce que si on
regarde si on se compare avec les autres
pays ils ont effectivement un taux de
chômage record en dessous de 3% pas tous
les États-Unis enfin la Suisse
l'Angleterre c'est aussi près de de 3%
ils ont vraiment des pénuries de main
d'oeuvre assez assez conséquente mais en
fait la qualité de l'emploi la précarité
en fait
est beaucoup plus développé là-bas donc
en fait c'est juste un choix c'est même
pas économique c'est un choix de société
qu'est-ce qu'on veut en fait est-ce
qu'on veut voilà on est aux Etats-Unis
le nombre de gens qui cumulent deux
trois emplois pour pouvoir s'en sortir
c'est une autre réalité ils n'ont pas
ils ont deux semaines de vacances nous
on en a on en a 5 plus en fait c'est
juste derrière il y a eu des équations
économiques comptables on peut calculer
combien ça coûte et c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on et en fait qu'est-ce qu'on
souhaite en fait derrière c'est à dire
le plein emploi c'est une réalité ça
veut pas dire que tout le monde va avoir
un CDI stable avec un bon salaire en fin
de mois c'est pas ça la définition du
plein emploi la pleine le plan emploi
c'est possible dans une économie parce
que une économie elle a besoin de
souplesse elle a besoin de il y a des
gens qui veulent travailler à temps
partiel aussi enfin voilà c'est notre
modèle social il est né de ça en disant
en fait il y a des aléas dans la vie et
on en fait collectivement on prend en
charge
il y a des cotisations et on prend et
l'erreur en fait qui a été faite par les
syndicats sur le sur en ce qui concerne
l'indemnité chômage c'est que les
salariés ne payent plus la cotisation
pardon de le dire mais si vous prenez le
cas de la Suisse et si vous prenez le
cas de toute une catégorie d'emplois par
exemple en Allemagne vous avez des bons
niveaux de salaire c'est pas vrai il y a
aussi des emplois précaires en Allemagne
je suis d'accord mais dans beaucoup de
catégories sociales vous avez des bons
niveaux de salaire donc le plein emploi
ne rime pas avec précarité ça c'est pas
vrai par contre ce qui est important
évidemment c'est de s'assurer ce que
vous dites et là vous avez raison c'est
que le plein emploi n'est pas le slogan
du pleine emploi n'est pas une manière
de forcer les gens à accepter n'importe
quel travail ça c'est sûrement réaliste
mais ce que je voudrais dire sur la
qualité de l'emploi c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup d'autres facteurs qui
interviennent il y a le stress il y a la
manière dont les patrons se comportent
il y a la législation du travail donc on
ne peut pas résumer la qualité d'un
emploi simplement au contrat de travail
il y a d'autres éléments qui rentrent en
jeu et il peut même arriver parfois que
le travail attend partiel soit bien vécu
par le salarié parce que ça lui convient
ça convient à son mode de vie donc lié
franchement le
plein emploi à la qualité soit pour dire
que c'est systématiquement la précarité
soit pour dire que c'est la panacée dans
les deux cas je pense que c'est pas vrai
alors vous avez évoqué la visite
d'Emmanuel Macron enfin moi je l'avais
fait d'abord dans mes titres d'ailleurs
on va y venir maintenant Emmanuel Macron
qui était resté silencieux pendant
l'examen de la réforme des retraites à
l'Assemblée nationale il profite de
cette semaine sans actualité
parlementaire on va dire pour
communiquer et choisit donc Rungis la
France qui travaille tôt écoutez
c'est un message de reconnaissance
d'abord devant toutes celles et ceux qui
permettent au pays de de tourner de
vivre vous savez on a beaucoup parlé
pendant le covid de cette France qui qui
tenait qui était là qui nous permettait
de continuer à aller faire les courses à
nous alimenter elle est là et c'est
celle aussi aujourd'hui qui malgré un
contexte d'inflation et difficile et là
pour là on est à la viande mais c'est
pareil au fruit et légumes au fromage au
poisson etc elle tient et c'est ce
travail qui nous permet de vivre et ce
que je veux dire ici c'est que le vrai
débat qu'on a à voir dans la société
c'est un débat sur le travail un débat
sur le travail ma petite coeffectivement
peut-être qu'il aurait fallu lancer ce
débat avant celui des retraites est-ce
qu'il est pas à contre emploi ou alors
pour éviter le jeu de mots à contretemps
Emmanuel Macron finalement oui
souvenez-vous Thomas d'Emmanuel Macron
des débuts le ministre de l'Économie le
futur président à l'époque le macronisme
c'était cette société du choix la
promesse de plus de mobilité d'une
émancipation individuelle et d'un
progrès collectif grâce notamment au
travail alors appliquer à une carrière
ou un parcours professionnel la grande
idée du chef résumé par un de ses
proches c'est celle-ci pouvoir
surcotiser à 30 ans et lever le pied à
60 ans mais au lieu de s'inscrire pour
dans cette philosophie le président
consomme l'essentiel de son capital
politique en ce moment en ce début de
mandat pour faire travailler les
Français deux ans de plus qui apparaître
punitif plus que révolutionnaire et
surtout à s'éloigner de ces engagements
de départ pourquoi Emmanuel Macron se
convertit au travailler plus de Nicolas
Sarkozy alors Emmanuel Macron est
traumatisé déjà par l'échec de son
système universel ça réforme de la
retraite à point de 2019 qui a
finalement périclité des conseillers et
des hauts fonctionnaires lui ont proposé
de coupler cette réforme des retraites
actuellement en débat au recul de la à
une loi sur le travail plus générale et
sur l'organisation du travail une espèce
de paquet en même temps en quelque sorte
sauf que le président n'en a pas voulu
il considérait que c'était trop
compliqué et en réalité l'Élysée est
davantage mobilisée sur cet objectifs
quantitatif dont on parle le plein
emploi au risque de délaisser des
préoccupations qualitatives sur le
travail à savoir sur les salaires sur le
temps de travail et sur les conditions
de travail qui ont pourtant fortement
émergé et depuis le covid le
gouvernement se retrouve donc contraint
d'être plutôt en réaction sur un sujet
sur lequel il aurait dû être à
l'avant-garde écouter ce que disait par
exemple le ministre de la Fonction
publique sur le sujet ce matin
il faut revenir à des arguments assez
simples nous devons travailler plus
longtemps mais on doit aussi aménager
les carrières s'intéresser davantage à
des questions sur la pénibilité comment
est-ce qu'on peut aménager son temps de
travail comment on peut aménager son
poste de travail comment on peut changer
de métier alors on a eu aussi des
responsables de la majorité des
ministres dont la première d'entre eux
Elisabeth borne qui se sont réunis lundi
soir dans une sorte de grandes messes
consacrée au partage de la valeur c'est
également Gabriel Attal le ministre qui
a récemment promu la semaine de quatre
jours qui est déjà en expérimentation
dans certaines administrations bref si
de tels chantiers avaient été ouvert
plus tôt on peut croire que les débats
sur la réforme des retraites et
l'hostilité qui s'exprime actuellement
aurait pu être assez différent président
à contretemps est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord Stéphanie
sur ce point précis oui
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que on
n'est pas assez nombreux à travailler
c'est à dire que si on se compare là
pour le coup
aux autres pays c'est ceux qui
travaillent travaillent beaucoup en fait
en terme on a le même quantité d'heures
par rapport à nos homologues étrangers
pourtant notre on a notre masse et pas
assez important c'est à dire on rentre
trop tard sur le marché du travail et on
en parle et donc ce qu'il faut
évidemment pour accroître la production
c'est simple si on est plus nombreux à
produire on produit plus l'idée l'idée
derrière et ça mais il y a une réalité
que le que le covid a soulevé on est
encore aujourd'hui avec plus de 300 000
postes vacants c'est-à-dire que les
entreprises
beaucoup de Français qui se posent des
questions sur effectivement la qualité
de leur emploi le sens de leur emploi ce
que ce que ce que fait leur entreprise
dans la société etc etc et donc c'est ce
que disait Mathilde c'est un ce chantier
là
il aurait pu être lancé avant celui des
retraites c'était peut-être plus
cohérent quand même je suis pas sûr que
le gouvernement l'état puisse tout faire
en fait c'est une problématique qui est
adressée à tout le monde avec des
salariés en fait qui se disent ben
finalement je ne veux pas travailler à
avec des horaires qui trop contraignants
le la période covid a véritablement
remis ça en cause et c'est au-delà du
salaire avec des jeunes qui veulent
se tourner plus vers la transition
écologique c'était ça devient une
nécessité de rendre la planète un peu
plus habitable qu'aujourd'hui en tout
cas la maintenir dans une situation
habitable donc il y a des grands
changements il y a une lame de fond qui
est véritablement là où il faut remettre
en question notre modèle de travail qui
a été mis en place jusqu'à présent et si
le chômage aujourd'hui ne baisse pas ne
progresse pas excusez-moi c'est parce
que aussi les entreprises ont bien vu
toute la difficulté qu'elles ont à
recruter à recruter leur tapisode c'est
difficile de recruter on garde ses
salariés de de en disant il y aura
peut-être une reprise on en aura besoin
absolument d'accord ils ont gardé
en tête ce qui s'est passé pendant le
covid l'Etat effectivement à maintenir à
travers la prise en charge du chômage
partiel mais il y a une télétravail ils
ont bien vu qu'au moment de la reprise
heureusement qu'ils avaient cette main
d'oeuvre et c'est et c'est et alors
effectivement et donc ça procède
effectivement de la même étape c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises se
disent on est dans une situation
globalement financière qui est plutôt
favorable il faut quand même dire en
France et donc on préfère conserver
notre nos effectifs alors que la
situation en train de se dégrader parce
que on prévoit que en cas de reprise au
moins on a ces effectifs donc c'est pas
réellement par des mesures
gouvernementales derrière il faut pas
oublier que le fer de lance est quand
même la croissance et ça restera
toujours la croissance Richard Werly
alors c'est même pas un clin d'oeil
tellement évident quoi le la référence à
Nicolas Sarkozy avec cette visite à à
rung sauf que Nicolas Sarkozy ça fait 11
ans qu'il est plus au pouvoir est-ce que
ce logiciel là il est adapté à la France
d'aujourd'hui la France poste covid ce
qui est sûr c'est que le slogan
travaillait plus pour gagner plus il
avait quand même marché politiquement
donc Emmanuel Macron il aime les
recettes qui marchent et peut-être que
Nicolas Sarkozy par ailleurs est assez
convaincant moi je crois pas qu'Emmanuel
Macron soit à contretemps je crois qu'il
est systématiquement piégé par le en
même temps c'est à dire qu'au fond il
veut toujours faire deux choses à la
fois et est-ce qu'il aurait dû découpler
ce que vous disiez c'est à dire d'abord
avoir une réforme sur le travail ou en
tout cas entamer une réflexion sur le
travail ensuite faire découler de cette
réflexion une réforme des retraites
ce que vous nous disiez
en même temps parce qu'il est persuadé
que c'est comme ça qu'on y arrive et
l'expérience de son premier mandat et
pour l'instant de son deuxième mandat
montre que c'est pas vraiment le cas
quelquefois il vaut mieux fonctionner
par étape qu'en essayant de ratisser
systématiquement large mais disons quand
même qu'entre temps était d'arriver la
crise des gilets jaunes et la pandémie
s'il y a contre-temps il est peut-être
aussi lié à ça Clément Carbonnier est-ce
que c'est pas une occasion manquée alors
peut-être que ça va arriver là mais d'un
grand débat collectif sur voilà pourquoi
on travaille quoi tout simplement ce
serait une bonne chose après vous vous
disiez est-ce que c'est à contre-temps
j'ai l'impression que c'est enfin il y a
une vraie question c'est est-ce que
c'est
vraiment un engagement dans un nouvel
manière de faire la politique ou si
c'est juste de la communication parce
que c'est pas juste la contretemps c'est
totalement à l'inverse de ce qui a été
fait depuis 2017 sur beaucoup de points
quand on écoute ce qu'il dit il parle
des conditions de travail il parle
d'aménager les carrières il y a eu un
certain nombre de d'ordonnance au début
d'ordonnance travail qui vont dans le
sens inverse qui vont vers donner moins
de pouvoir de négociation au syndicats
qui ont enlevé les CHSCT qui vérifie les
les conditions de travail il a même
parlé et là je pense que c'est un lapsus
parce que il a parlé quand il donnait
l'exemple sur la sur la fin c'est pas
une astuce c'est une erreur sur la
pénibilité il dit les gens qui ont des
carrières pénibles c'est normal ils
partent plutôt et il a cité le port de
charge lourdes or le port de charge
lourdes c'était effectivement considéré
comme un critère de pénibilité jusqu'en
2017 quand sous sa présidence a été
enlevé donc aujourd'hui ce n'est plus un
critère de pénibilité et quand on
regarde les critères de pénibilité
restant c'est pas de la pénibilité c'est
de l'extrême pénibilité donc aujourd'hui
les critères de billibilité ne sont pas
prises en compte et ne sont pas prises
en compte notamment par rapport à ces
réformes donc ce serait un virage
complet et donc là on peut se poser la
question ce serait une bonne chose si
vraiment on commençait à s'intéresser
aux conditions de travail
aux évolutions de carrière si on
s'intéressait à tout ça à la
rémunération il a parlé de la
rémunération de la même manière il a
diminué les capacités de négociation le
SMIC ne prend plus jamais il est évalué
que avec l'inflation il prend plus il y
a peu de il y a peu de hausse de la
productivité mais il y en a quand même
et le SMIC n’en bénéficie absolument pas
de des hausses de prédictivité qui a eu
donc en fait il parle de rémunération
mais en fait il y a eu une politique
était dans le sens inverse il parle de
conditions de travail il y a une
politique et dans le sens inverse donc
si c'est l'annonce d'un virage c'est une
très bonne nouvelle j'ai peur que ce
soit plus de la communication qu'un vrai
virage on a bien compris une dernière
réaction dans ce dans ce débat celle de
Dominique corona secrétaire adjoint de
l'INSA c'était lors de la conférence de
des huit principaux syndicats français
des organisations de jeunesse c'était
aussi de la CGT en prévision de la
journée de mobilisation d'action du 7
mars il réagit à cette visite
présidentielle au marché de Rungis il a
essayé effectivement à Rungis d'aller
voir la France qui se lève tout la
France qui est cassée et des salariés
lui ont dit mais qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire nous à 64 ans comment va pouvoir
effectivement continuer à travailler
pour nourrir la France entre guillemets
alors que rien n'est fait sur la
pénibilité rien n'est fait effectivement
sur l'emploi des seniors rien n'est fait
dans cette dans cette dans cette
retraite pour que effectivement les gens
soient mieux et mieux accompagnés avant
la retraite donc aujourd'hui le bon sens
c'est lui qui devrait l'avoir et c'est
lui qui devrait écouter effectivement ce
qui se passe dans la France aujourd'hui
des territoires Richard werlis ça pose
on est en train d'en débattre il y a une
vraie question sur le rapport des
Français au travail dans un article
récent publié dans Vous vous rappelez
cette cette enquête je crois que c'est
de l'Ifop qui est quand même assez
intéressante sur ce que nous Français
pensons notre vie professionnelle tout à
fait il y a globalement on en avait
parlé d'ailleurs sur ce plateau je me
souviens que la sociologue Dominique
MEDA il y a une je dirais pas une
appréhension des Français par rapport au
travail une appréhension croissante le
travail ne leur donne plus qu'ils en
attendent et le paradoxe c'est qu'il
s'investisse d'un côté beaucoup dans
leur travail peut-être beaucoup trop si
vous le comparez encore une fois aux
voisins européens moi je suis toujours
frappé qu'en France on accorde plus
d'importance au travail qu'en Suisse par
exemple on vous en parle plus
spontanément c'est un objet de
conversation c'est dans votre vie
quotidienne beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs
mais on est systématiquement déçu ou
assez souvent déçu parce que le travail
ne vous apporte pas ce que vous en
attendez ça c'est la pire des situations
parce que ça provoque des frustrations
et effectivement là alors la visite à
Rungis c'était évidemment liée au salon
de l'agriculture qui arrive mais aller à
Rungis faire l'éloge de ceux qui se
lèvent tôt qui sont souvent des gens qui
veulent aussi partir tôt en retraite
c'était quand même assez politiquement
risqué effectivement un dernier mot
Stéphanie Villers sur le peut-être le
comment les entreprises changent en ce
moment en France je sais pas ce que vous
pensez de ça mais justement pour
répondre à ces enjeux de qualité de
travail de difficultés de recrutement de
génération qui veut donner du sens à son
à son emploi il y a quand même pas mal
d'entreprises qui sont en train de se
transformer oui alors voilà alors il y a
deux choses déjà je voulais dire que la
grande démission elle est pas uniquement
en France elle est partout elle est
mondiale on est quand même en train
véritablement de changer collectivement
ensuite les entreprises on leur a
accordé des flexibilités pour peut-être
licencier davantage mais on voit en fait
que ça allait fait inverse puisque je
vous disais que au contraire les
entreprises veulent conserver leur
effectif parce que en cas de reprise et
préfère encore avoir leurs salariés
dont l'entreprise qu'à l'extérieur elle
allait dire j'ai recherché parce que
recherchez des talents aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est un problème donc les
entreprises françaises s'adaptent
s'adaptent tellement que on voit que si
on regarde la composition de la
croissance aujourd'hui en France c'est
pèlerinage qui eux effectivement ont un
mode moral vraiment en berne et les
entreprises qui continuent à investir
sur tout le tous les trimestres de 2022
le l'impulsion de la croissance ça a été
les entreprises qui investissent donc ça
c'est quand même un c'est véritablement
un facteur d'optimisme il y a pas que
des choses qui vont mal en France c'est
les entreprises en fait
conservent en fait la vision long terme
en disant de toute manière on va passer
cette période d'inflationniste qui est
assez compliquée on courbe le dos mais
derrière on a notamment sur les critères
de de transition écologique il faut
investir et on investit on voit
véritablement que les entreprises
françaises vont vers cette voie voilà et
notamment aussi le digital et se mettent
et celles qui sont pas mis au digital on
le voit bien en fait cette semaine il y
a eu effectivement pas mal de
raz-de-marée avec des faillites parce
que elles se sont pas mis en ordre de
marche je parle de toutes les enseignes
de textiles qui sont en difficulté c'est
celles qui n'ont pas réussi à se mettre
à l'air du numérique et ça ça donne une
alerte qui était qui déjà auprès des
entreprises françaises où elles se
disent il faut véritablement qu'on
prenne le train du numérique pour se
mettre en ordre de marche merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat Clément Carboni je rappelle le
titre de votre livre coécrit avec Bruno
palier les femmes les jeunes et les
enfants d'abord investissement social et
économie de la qualité publiée au presse
universitaire de France